Good. Good. Yeah.
Okay, you can find it any old way you
can. Just like the other technique.
Sometimes you grab with that hand,
sometimes you step. Sometimes you grab
with the other hand, sometimes it
shouldn't matter, right? Try it.
[Music]
You're time to rest. You've been working
hard all week. This is the rest time.
[Music]
There you go.
Yeah.
[Music]
Rider instead of pushing him down.
Hey, hey, hey.
[Music]
Okay, take a break.
So, again, I don't know what I'm doing.
I I have to go back on film. I think I
changed directions a couple times, which
tells you I can be on the inside of the
circle. I can be on the outside of the
circle. I still use the same centrifugal
force. Okay. Um,
I didn't ever go all the way to the
inside and do the admin, but of course
that's always there. But I tried to just
stick with the outer hand using this
energy for the adhesion. Okay. You can
see how I'm still very mobile. I'm just
walking around. Okay. But um, still very
connected, still moving the center.
Okay. So, uh, stand up.
Try to relax more. Shake it out. I know
some of you have done systemic training
and to me this is like we're in that
we're in that ballpark now. The idea is
to be loose, dynamic, fluid. Okay. But
to use these force engines, okay?
All right. Go for it. Change partners.
[Music]
Shing it down.
Yeah, take it right there. Very nice.
Got to tighten it up. You got to tighten
it up to do the throw.
Try to keep that pace.
[Applause]
That's it. Yeah.
Think about what you did.
You got him where he's kind of aiming
down. But just relax. You see how I'm
trying to move him? So then you let
yourself move. Okay, there you go. He's
aiming down, right? And so you're like,
I can't get to the just the outside here
now. Got it. And so what you ended up
doing was you just turned it here. Then
the then the centrifugal energy takes
the hip out. Okay. So good. Very nice.
Sean did a double double turn. I don't
Okay. You know what he did? Yeah. That
was pretty cool too though. So instead
instead of going for the no
I think uh the guy turned the guy turn
turn turn turn turn turn turn turn turn
turn turn turn turned towards like this.
Yeah and then so Sean came around the
came around the other side and then one
more time I knew back into the
technique. Okay, so just chase the
feeling for now. Just play try to relax.
Lose the effort. Go.
Very
nice. Try to do it in stes.
That's the one. That's the one where you
come under one.
Don't touch.
[Music]
Come on, Leo. Go for it.
It's looking good. It's looking good.
Wait.
Okay. Um,
again ground. Okay. Ground cuz stuff
goes stuff goes wrong. Um,
what what I mean by this is let's say
let me
So I'm kind of like this. Yeah. You can
can use that force like that, right?
It's a real force. It's not a magic
force. But I'm not grounding there. Do
do you understand? So
as you're as you're doing as you're
feeling the forces you're here, someone
should be able and you're like let's go
and they're not going to move. You get
that? Okay. That we're kind of getting
floaty here.
You don't know if you're going to have
to hit them with the elbow or something.
Okay. So you have to be always in this
mobile stability, not just mobility.
Okay.
All right. Sh stand up. Shake it out.
and get a new partner and go.
You went with someone light. Go with
someone bigger.
Good bases.
Got to get that neck
and the UK doesn't do anything. Some of
you are already falling just from the
centrifugal energy.
[Music]
That's it.
There you go.
Get good face when you do that.
Don't wait for her, Angelo. She's
moving. Don't really start moving.
Move. Yes, there it is. Be ready. Get
your other hand ready. A little late on
the other hand. Move. That's it. There
it is. Yeah, that much easier now.
Okay, rest.
down. It's so easy. It gets stupid now.
It is. It's stupid. Okay. So, let's say
I go over here and this isn't working.
Well, that's where the other hand comes
in, right? And the same thing. Don't try
to hook the head. You're going to use
the centrifugal energy this way.
The same stop. See, I did that stop
again. Okay? And it's just if it's
there. If I'm over here, I don't cut it.
It's not that I am I don't know. I'm not
going like this.
Can you guys see that? I got to get that
other force to come back
here.
So by you can see that my co is going
changing feet. Okay, make sense? Now I'm
not saying do it. I'm not saying try it.
But if this is not there, that's there.
And then you're using the same force
just on the other side. Okay, change
partners.
That's the tension no arm.
Right. Try to move before she's coming.
Don't wait. Don't wait. There. There you
go.
[Music]
That's it. Get a good face. Kind of move
like this.
That's it. You got to spin it back
towards you.
That's on the wrong side of the hat.
Almost. Okay. So,
this this is what you're doing. Okay.
You can see The guy just will spit out.
Okay. So, I get that going. Then a sharp
turn. You feel that?
A sharp turn. It could be fast.
You feel it? And I do the same thing on
this side. So, I'm not taking you around
the circle. Eventually, you're going to
get out of the circle.
I have to go here.
Okay. Does that make sense? Okay. Try
it.
This was not This is what makes it not
an acceleration throw. Remember, you've
heard me complain about acceleration
throws. I'm not just accelerating him.
Okay, try it. And be as light as you can
be moving first. You're late. You're
late on the catch. Already have a good
possibility
after there. It's time for the ball or
you got hit. Okay.
One more.
Feel better.
Here's
the inside.
That's it.
[Applause]
Lighter and lighter and lighter. Start
moving. Lighter and lighter and lighter.
We're getting heavier and heavier and
heavier. Lighter and lighter and
lighter.
Lighter, lighter, wider,
lighter, lighter, lighter,
lighter, lighter.
So again, you got to watch me. Don't
want Don't watch.
Just look at me.
What do I look like? That's This is what
I look like. But what's it feel like?
that. Okay. Right. I'm winded and
tired already. Okay. Even you can see he
had a lot of downwardness, right? Why
would I try to go over the top of that?
I just let him go out of the way.
Connect from there. There's the There it
is. Okay. Try it again.
Lighter, lighter, lighter.
Good base. Let's get a better base.
[Music]
Lighter. Lighter. Last.
Lighter. Lighter. Lighter.
face your feet got twisted.
Okay.
So again if I right space time is my
that's how I define my what's the space
time. Okay.
Space confidence determine what I want
to do, what I can do. What's my
environment incident?
It's not fully determined by what I want
to do.
I want it to come over the top. It's too
much pressure. Fine.
But in that again I have to use the
right force engines.
Can't just use the other force engines
because I have to know while I'm working
on this technique. This technique is not
the fight technique.
The fight technique is what again what
we just said. It's totally dependent
upon the particular totality of
circumstances.
So I have to be in this universal
ability. That's my true force engine.
That's all I use in my training. Okay.
So if I feeling tension, I got no I
don't don't send that round down. You
did not focus.
You do not see the grains on the tape.
You just see a haze down there in the
shape of a silhouette. Don't throw lead.
I feel tension or anxiety in my body.
Just stop.
Just stop the technique. Don't try to
get that technique anymore cuz that's
not the force engines. Does that make
sense? So that's where the discipline
comes in that you come in. You yourself,
you're going to say, "No, no, no." And
you're going to try for this.
Now, here eventually, I'm not going to
do it to you. You came all this way on
the camp, but here eventually I do take
you off the mat. On the rage, I do take
the gun away from you.
You're throwing lead, not knowing what
we're doing. Okay? But you have to be
the person in you that that's telling
you, I'm going to try to do this stuff.
So you know if you're flexing, you know
if you're contesting, you know if you're
down vector training or not, you know if
you have your center or not,
you know if you have anxiety, tension,
if you're having any kind of emotional
reactivity, just stop. Just stop. What's
What's it hurt? What's it hurt? It
doesn't hurt. You got me. So So
like
you're here. What did I do wrong
already? I waited for him. So you let's
say you you like nothing wrong nothing
happened but you knew sorry let's try it
again okay and you go again not it okay
so let's try it again
and we'll do sensei's rules
but you should be sensei you should stop
yourself before I stop you okay all
right new partners
You're ahead, Chris. Don't do it. You
didn't have this center. You're ahead.
Maya, you're hooking.
You don't have the the reverse spiral,
right? No base.
No reverse spirals.
There it is. Good. So, one out of four.
You're at 25%.
Okay.
So, take you train. Wait. You train.
Let's say you train, you had the
potential to train four days a week, but
you dropped down to one day a week,
right? You see now you do it one day a
week.
Someone do the math.
One day a week, 72 weeks,
I got 72 hours.
Got it? Versus someone else who's
actually training,
accumulating the reps, four times that
amount. Same thing with Tristan. You go,
"Hey, it's 10 free throws. Let's get a
percentage every time so he stops
throwing up shit."
25. He shoots a 25% out of 10.
That's got to be unacceptable.
Okay? So, you got to hold yourself. You
don't need me. I'm not saying anything
you haven't heard already. I'm not
saying anything that need explaining,
which means you knew it. You're just not
holding yourself to it. So, sometimes I
go too fast for me to stay in the moment
because my mind is fed. Go slow. Go
slower. Just go smoother. You just can't
stop. But there's no there's no rule
against how slow you're going. Just rule
against stopping. Okay. And try it
again. Tell your come in a little slower
for me. Go.
your feet toes out and heel weight at
the end. Good face like
that face.
Okay, thank you for giving me the
perfect example of what I was talking
about.
You got a lot of tension in your glutes.
I don't know if there's a stick up
there, but it looks like it. Okay,
relax, relax, relax, relax, relax,
relax. Okay,
you're like you're like this. Okay, so
don't do that. And then the desire
to succeed is making it worse as you're
moving. So, I'll relax as long as I keep
him moving. Keep him moving.
get the technique. Okay. As long as I
keep him moving, that of course the
centrifugal energy together.
All right. But I'm going to try to
relax. And just like today when I said
you're closer, you're further along in
the cultivation set. If you flex,
release, and then got this place, you're
closer. Same thing here. You're closer
to getting this if you release that
tension and keep him moving while the
tension is released than if you throw
him really fast and hard and we're all
stiff like this. Okay, let's go.
Discipline up.
This comes around the last time. You
also have to find out, right?
[Music]
Lighter and lighter. And looping and
moving.
[Music]
95.
Come on. Relax. Relax.
I know cuz you're pressing like a body.
That's it, Derek. Like more release.
[Music]
Less tension, less speed, more presence.
Good base. Better base.
Better base. Good.
Relax.
A little a little short. Your right is
not short.
Good movement.
[Music]
Yes. Yes. Yes. Okay. Very good. All
right. Take a break.